the queen is gonna be making an address
to the nation later on urging us to
maintain our self-discipline and resolve
just how important is that message gonna
be well I'm I welcome the fact that Her
Majesty will be making one of these very
rare addresses because it recognizes
what an extraordinary and difficult time
this is for the nation and this point
about holding our resolve is so
important the vast majority of people
are following the public health advice
which is absolutely critical and staying
at home but there are a small minority
of people who are not still not doing
that it's quite unbelievable frankly to
see the that there are some people who
are not following the advice but the
vast and overwhelming majority of people
are and so I hope that Her Majesty will
lift the spirits and also thank
everybody who is doing the right thing
by staying at home because that is the
best way to control the spread of this
virus and the fastest way to get us out
of this you say it's unbelievable that
some people are breaking the rules of
the lockdown but I just wonder if you
could clarify a little bit about what we
are we aren't allowed to do the weather
is very lovely this weekend
not everyone has a garden is it
acceptable to sit down in the park and
sunbathe if you are maintaining social
distancing we're absolutely clear that
you should not leave your home unless
it's for one of four reasons for medical
reasons to buy food to go to work if you
can't work at home or for exercise and
of course I understand how difficult
this is but the problem is that when you
go out it's not only that you might
directly interact with somebody closer
than two meters it's also that whenever
you that you can spread the virus
through touching something which
somebody else then touches or you could
pick it up that way so we're we're
crystal clear in the guidance of what
people should and shouldn't do that
guidance is backed up in law it is not a
request it is a requirement in law and
people need to
follow it and I just say this to the
very small minority as you say of people
who are choosing to flout the guidance
you are putting other's lives at risk
and you are putting yourself in harm's
way and so we are we are very very clear
and so does that mean just to be crystal
clear that sunbathing is against the law
sunbathing is against the rules that
have been set out for important public
health reasons and you know I wish I
didn't have to say this but I do because
the whole country wants to come through
this crisis the whole country wants to
come through this of course as quickly
as possible and the fastest way to come
through the guidin the crisis and to
save lives and to protect the NHS and
reduce the pressure on the NHS the
fastest way to do that is to follow the
guidance and to stay at home unless
you've got one of the four reasons that
we've set out you say the fastest way to
effectively get at the lockdown is to
follow the rules
yesterday professor Neil Ferguson of
Imperial korrok College advising the
government said that the restrictions
could be eased in weeks if people follow
the rules is that right
well the I'm not going to get into a
conditional you know if because what
matters is that people do follow the
rules and then we'll be able to to make
some progress but there's only one
message that's going to come out from
the government over this which is you
really have to stay at home unless you
have one of those four reasons
stay at home because that then will slow
the spread of the virus so the
scientists can do their analysis on what
happens under different scenarios but in
a way that second order because we don't
know how quickly this the spread of this
virus will will stop because it depends
on how people behave so every single
person watching this program can do
their bit
get us out of this faster and they do
their bit by following the social
distancing rules at the same time though
lots of people will feel that they're
making a big sacrifice here particularly
those people who live in overcrowded
accommodation those people who perhaps
have mental health issues those people
who may not even feel safe at home and
you have your adviser going on saying
that it could be lifted in a matter of
weeks
surely you need to provide some clarity
here on how long we could be in this
situation for well I'd love to be able
to provide even more clarity than we
have and we were clear when the when
those who've gone into shielding those
who are the most medically vulnerable
that that would we would expect that to
last at least 12 weeks but oh the truth
is and one of the difficulties of this
situation that we're all in one of the
difficulties is that there are
uncertainties and there are
uncertainties because we're still
learning information about there about
the disease itself and the science
continues to to improve but there's also
in uncertainties as to how quickly we
can we can stop the spread of this virus
because it does depend very directly on
how people behave there's a direct link
from what proportion of people follow
the rules through to the pressure on the
NHS and how quickly we can reduce the
pressure on the NHS through to how many
lives are lost and how quickly we can
lift the the very extraordinary measures
and I understand how impactful the
measures are of course I do and they
they impact people differently according
to their circumstances I get that but
this is why we need resolve as a nation
all to follow that those rules so that
we can get out of it as fast as possible
okay and according to the men on Sunday
and there's a bit of a battle or debate
going on between yourself and the
Chancellor about when to lift the
lockdown perhaps understandably you've
got an eye on the NHS he has no eye on
the economy do you recognize that
no we're working very closely together
and what matters is that we can get out
of this as fast as possible and to do
that we have to make sure that that as
many people as possible follow the rules
and so that we can we can slow the
spread so of course my my job as health
secretary is to build up the NHS and
look out for the NHS and support the
people in the NHS in public health
England and across the board who are who
are working so hard to try to to resolve
this and I think that Richie's doing an
absolutely brilliant job as as
Chancellor the measures that he's put in
place to support businesses to support
people self-employed people and employed
people are absolutely phenomenal and in
fact he's been lauded around the world
for the first class for economic
response that we've got in this country
and we all want to get through this as
quickly as possible and get them get and
lift some of these extraordinary
measures but we can't do that until it's
safe to do so okay lots of praise there
the Chancellor in the answer there the
big question of course is what is the
government's long-term strategy for
getting out of the lockdown
well the first thing we have to do is it
is is flatten the curve and turn the
curve of infections downwards and we
have seen some progress on that but
we're not there yet and then once we've
done that we'll be able to think about
the the next steps and we're doing the
work on that but we'll be able to test
what are those next steps because this
is the critical thing what are the next
steps is it a vaccine is it treatment is
it testing what is the way out well
we're working on all of those three and
they're all very important treatments to
make sure that if we can if we can
improve the treatments and if we can get
the science behind the treatments better
than more people who become ill we'll be
able to to survive and people would be
less ill a vaccine of course would be
really if it would be incredible but it
has to be safe and not do more harm than
good and it takes time to develop a
vaccine like that but we in fact the UK
has fun has put more funding into the
global search for a vaccine than any
other country around the world and I'm
working very closely with the differed
secretary and the foreign secretary on
that because they've been leading that
global that global search and put their
budgets into that and and then as as
well as obviously treatments and
vaccines testing matters as well and we
had a very big discussion about testing
over the last week and we have a clear
strategy to increase the amount of
testing just want to ask about that
testing because many people say that
that is one of the clearest ways out of
the lockdown you of course to set this
aim to reach a hundred thousand tests a
day by the end of April but if you just
look at the figures if a minute around
ten thousand tests have been carrying
out carried out a day just 11 days ago
Boris Johnson said that we'd have
250,000 tests a day hopefully very soon
we'll still stuck around 10,000 I mean
the numbers sound great you want to
believe them but on this record is that
actually achieve
yes it's gonna be hard I and it's and
and it's going to require an awful lot
of people to put their shoulders to the
wheel in the life sciences industry
across the NHS and supported by the the
work that public health England has been
doing brilliantly on the expanding
testing we set a goal of 10,000 tests a
day by the end of March and we hit that
goal we at the end of February we only
had we had under 2,000 tests a day so we
are on a very rapid ramp up but we
clearly need to see that go further
I mean testing of course is crucial to
get NHS staff back onto the frontline
and I think there is still a bit of
confusion about just how many NHS staff
are currently off because of suspected
coronavirus or the Royal Clojure
physician survey their members estimate
that around 15% are off what proportion
of frontline NHS workers are off work
it's about 8% on the latest figures and
that that's the that's the actual figure
the the the Royal College did do a
survey but it wasn't an accurate
representation so the 8% at the moment
but obviously know it's it's it's stable
at the press conference I was asked the
question about doctors if about it's
about 5.7 percent of doctors 8 percent
of NHS staff overall and those figures
are stable but we want to get them down
obviously in one of the ways that we do
that is by getting the amount of testing
for NHS staff up another criticism as
well has been on the amount of
protective equipment on the frontline
and I know you said that the the
available equipment is there but there's
been delays getting it through there's
been reports that the US has been
intercepting some of the medical
equipment found for European countries
you concerned about some protectionism
here well I'm I'm very concerned that we
keep open global supply chains both for
protective equipment and also for
medicines you know making sure that
medicines can come in
because they're often made in several
different countries on their journey
from being raw chemicals through to the
medicines that that that that people
take that save lives and so we must be a
beacon for the openness of those those
supply chains across the world and make
sure that we win that argument it
doesn't benefit anyone for all countries
around the world to start putting up
barriers now at the same time we have to
recognize the reality of the challenges
here and boost domestic production so
for instance I'm really proud of
Burberry who have switched their
factories from making their top-end
garb to making gowns for the NHS I think
that's absolutely fantastic and in the
same way that Formula One has switched
from upgrading their amazing cars to
making ventilators you know so we are
going to have to have more of a national
effort domestically but I also think we
should be out there making the argument
for countries around the world to be
coming together and working together on
this rather than putting in place
barriers now both you and the Prime
Minister tested positive for covert 19
you're out about you're doing press
conferences you're doing interviews
Boris Johnson is still in South
isolation with a temperature just how
ill is the Prime Minister oh he's okay
I've been talking to him every day often
several times a day throughout this
throughout the time that both of us were
off and so he's very much got his hand
on the tiller he's but he's still got a
temperature in a way it shows you know
this virus affects different people
differently I was lucky I had to pretty
rough days and then I bounced back and
some people do get it pretty mildly and
then for others it's very very serious
and the Prime Minister is not at that
end of the spectrum he's he's working
away inside Downing Street but he's
protecting others by making sure that he
too
follows the the clear public health
advice which is to which is the self
isolate if you've got symptoms you can
see why there is some concern about
health of the Prime Minister though and
at a time when he is still of course
leading the response to what could be
the biggest crisis since World War two
doctors say that if a temperature
persists for more than a week more than
seven days you could be at risk of
developing pneumonia has he been visited
by doctors I don't know and even if I
did I wouldn't go into details on in in
public what I could say is that in
dealing with him and working with him
every day he's in he's in good spirits
but he's also being absolutely careful
and cautious to follow public health
advice both for for the direct impact
and also as an example to the nation
okay
and now labour has a new leader Kirsten
oh he says he wants to work
constructively with the government do
you think we could ever see a government
of national unity I don't think that's
on the cards but I do think that working
together is important I think that this
is not a time when anybody wants to see
political parties fighting between them
in fact I've had a very constructive
relationship with John Ashworth the
shadow health secretary who who is you
know applied some constructive criticism
but it's been genuinely constructive and
and that's been the tone in which he's
done it is fine and I think that what
people want to see is their politicians
coming together at this time of national
crisis to try to solve the problem
because frankly all that matters is that
we as a country get through this as well
as we can as fast as we can